et maintenant maintenant mesdames
messieurs nous allons accueillir un
ressuscité
voici patrick dupont
patrick du bonbon soir bonsoir salut
voila je reste comme ça ça y est je suis
bien je suis installé tout va bien merci
au revoir merci d'être venus il vous
reste neuf mais enfin bon c'est pas le
même usage en 100 kg il va pousser bien
bien alors dans la série dupond et
dupont
la semaine dernière on avait aurélie
dupont et cette semaine on à patrick
dupond voilà donc vous vous la
connaissez aurélie dupont cela d'or
c'est une de mes chouchoute vos goûts
grande rien et c'est une très très belle
danseuse surtout au coude il est plein
de choses dans la tête aller a lancé ici
qu'elle était toute seule et vous savez
que cette émission servent à ça aussi
patrie elle sera pas ça longtemps alors
vous et vous sur incroyable quoi ces
retours devant fermer vrai mais si
janvier 2004 - sur un lit d'hôpital il
alors à l'époque vous étiez allongé
comme ça c'était le tour de normandie
j'étais allongé il vous entendiez les
pompiers qui disait vie dont on est avec
patrick dupont il est pas beau à voir
n'est pas beau à voir mais il s'en
sortira ouais ouais mais ce qui est
formidable c'est que exactement dix mois
jour pour jour après cet accident
c'est à dire dans trois jours le rideau
se lève à l'espace pierre cardin et qui
est-ce qui danse et qui est-ce qui
chante c'est bien celui est donc quelque
part bah ouais voilà
et
les enceintes et ça m'arrive à moi ça
peut arriver aux autres les sportifs ont
une faculté de se rétablir
il ya les sportifs et gérard depardieu
c'est l'été le 4 go mais c'est vrai il
faut être fort alors donc j'ai tout
repris à zéro vous avec votre votre père
votre maître max bozzoni donc j'étais
allé dans des données vous dites des
studios il ya des petites ballerines de
6 ans les tout recommencer rodier avec
des petites filles de 6 et des petits
garçons de 6 7 ans qui m'ont regardé
avec des yeux un peu halluciné j'ai
recommencé doucement avec lui et puis
quelques semaines plus tard j'étais sur
la scène de l'espace cardin et je
commençais à relancer à chanter et à
jouer la comédie et c'est bien je suis
super content si vous voyez un homme
heureux là bas alors la comédie musicale
qui s'appelle l'air de paris c 17
novembre à l'espace cardin
alors c'est basé sur quoi surtout les
grands airs de paris mais c'est aussi
bien ses 45 chansons en fait on a
choisis dans le répertoire de toutes les
chansons qui étaient écrites sur paris
45 des plus belles qui sont des
certaines des vrais chef-d'oeuvre des
bijoux tels la complainte de la butte la
valse à mille temps rue de lappe pigalle
et herat est en fait c'est l'histoire
d'une pro du jeune provinciale qui au
monde millions landowski et manon
landowski le jour de son mariage au
moment de dire oui a dit non on dit mais
attend pour quad était dingue on peut
pas dire non c'est épouser un héritier
un riche héritier est dit mais enfin
vous avez rien compris à paris qui
m'attend et elles sont dans le train
d'harry elle arrive à paris dans un
dancing dont le patron c'est moi et je
lui dis alors coco tu veux voir paris
donne moi la main je la prend par la
main et je lui dis regarde là bas à
droite c'est la rue de la peur brider la
haute en joyeux voilà et ça commence
comme ça vous chante et là oui je chante
je chante à peu près 40 chansons
vous avez une bonne capacité pulmonaire
pour vous c'est pareil j ouer j'ai 5
litres à peu près 5 litres à quelque 2
dead d'oxygène mais ça va très très bien
c'est la même scène plus que la normale
et c'est quoi exactement comme un
accordéon notre prof de chant nous dit
toujours regarder roland quand ils
ouvrent comme ça et donc car le vent ces
16 ou alors un patrick dupont au
printemps un livre est sorti qui
s'appelle étoiles voilà que chez fayard
et alors on apprend pas mal de choses
sur vous c'est un homme destiné à ces
étonnantes
d'abord josé paccaud ni votre père non
j'ai même pas si les partis ou si votre
mère l'a mis dehors vous savez
maintenant les contredit mois suivant
suivant la personne qui raconte
l'histoire ces troubles tout ce qu'il ya
d'important en tous les cas c'est qu'il
ya six ans je les ai rencontrés pour la
première fois par azmi s'y attendait
c'est génial l'histoire d'abord je dis
vous avez été élevé donc pas beau père
lucien mon beau père voulait pas que la
collision mais ma grand mère et un jour
racontez nous cette histoire en thalasso
en 94 c'est extraordinaire puisqu'on
était en thalasso après après les soins
et le dîner du soir on se faisait une
petite coupette de champagne tranquille
le thé et le barman vient vers nous il
dit voilà il ya le monsieur là bas au
fond à gauche qui vous offre une
bouteille de don pérignon alors je
renvoie la bouteille en disant non dit
au monsieur là bas que j'accepte pas le
champagne des messieurs que je connais
pas puis le monsieur insiste une fois
puis deux fois puis trois fois puis à
chaque fois je renvoie en direct et non
je suis pas libre toute façon ce soir et
je suis avec ma mère donc un peu de
décence s'il vous plaît qui garde son
champagne on verra ça plus tard
éventuellement puis il insiste encore ma
mère me regarde et me dit écoute tu
devrais regarder à gauche quand même
alors je regarde comme ça j'ai dit au
fait tu as tu vas te marrer mais le mec
là on dirait moi avec vingt ans de plus
et 20 kg de plus dit bah ouais je dis
quoi bein ouai dit bah ouais 20 ans de
plus et 20 kg s'est effectivement vrai
c'est ton père est un vieux blancs la
mer est assez énorme alors besoin ils
sont vrais résume m dit oui c'est ton
père et j'ai fait signe au monsieur puis
il est venu on s'est serré la main
il a regardé ma mère est là j'ai compris
j'ai dit ok je vous laisse oui je suis
désolé c'est un werder est survenu
j'avais compris brialy
ce que vous avez construit après c'est
que vous avez vu leur regard vous avez
vu se regarder vous avez fait passer un
truc très fort en du retard des gens
s'aiment aussi fort quand je suis né ma
mère avait 16 ans et demi lui de ne pas
en avoir beaucoup plus c'est bon il
s'est passé vraiment bien évidemment et
quand ils se sont revus comme ça au bout
de 36 ans
oui trente cinq ans donc j'ai vu dans
leurs yeux qu'ils se passait quelque
chose je les ai laissés ensuite survenue
jeudi bon on va la boire cette bouteille
mais on va se parler un peu quand même
parce qu'on ne peut pas en rester là et
donc on a parlé jusqu'à 4 5 heures du
matin on a descendu six ou sept
bouteilles je n'ai pas conduit après et
donc on est rentrés tranquille et puis
maintenant se voient presque assez
régulièrement j'ai découvert que chez
lui chez votre vrai père il y avait une
pièce qui vous était dédiée en plus en
allant chez lui où j'étais une espèce de
mausolées patrick dupond j'ai dit tu vas
m'arracher tout ça il y avait des photos
de moi partout four à tous les âges de
ma vie dans ma nomination danseur étoile
ma nomination directeur quand j'ai été
décoré de chevalier des arts et lettres
je ne sais pas possible tu peux pas
vivre dont il va être très malheureuse
envers patrice finalement parce que je
suis je suis autre chose que ce à quoi
doivent être malheureux de vous voir
réussir comme ça ne pas pouvoir vous le
dira pas pouvoir vous parler c'est sa
chance et cette histoire dans l'histoire
de barbara ah ben oui racontez nous
livrons baissé
tout le monde sait ça mais non pas lui
est arrivé la même aventure elle a
trouvé son père plus très tard fêtards
ou est-elle là elle l'a ratée en plus
que vous après malheureusement il a
disparu et elle a écrit nantes
ouais voilà dans le train qui la
ramenait après l'enterrement lahidji
vous savez tout non mais j'ai quelques
relais dans les chanteurs c'est barbara
léo ferré brel brassens écrire alors la
vocation de vous traîtres et où vous
avez été découvert votre votre vocation
parce que quand vous aviez trois ans le
dimanche après le repas familial fameux
repas c'est le fameux repas du dimanche
qu'on a tous connu avec le monbazillac
et les et les gâteaux secs vous montiez
debout sur la table convenu de
débarrasser il y avait le mange disque
rouge et donc sur twist again je dansais
là au milieu de la table il y avait mon
grand père avec sa deuxième femme ma
grand mère qui est l épouse de mon grand
père avec son deuxième mari et ma mère
avec lucien son deuxième mari voilà et
sa forme est une espèce de pyramides et
moi j'étais en haut de la pyramide les
gens dansaient twist again comme ça
j'avais 3 ans jusqu'à jusqu'à ce que je
tombe à épuisement jeu que vous oubliez
dans votre culotte
c'était un plaisir attendez vous
imaginez le public en ont vous avez une
énergie donc extraordinaire là à
l'époque dont vous dossier jusqu'à
jusqu'à plus soif dimanche après-midi
sur la table de la cuisine familiale
mais très jeune on découvre chez vous
une énergie extraordinaire vous dormez
trois quatre heures par nuit
quand vous avez 14 ans vous êtes un peu
le chef de la bande
vous faites les 400 cours vous appelle
tape dur et vous êtes agité et colérique
un peu épileptique et votre mère et
c'est comme ça qu'il est devenu
patrick dupond votre mère vous en faire
dans une chambre obscure membres dans sa
chance nous sommes sur le grand lit
enfin la chambre de lucien et c'est
ouais et de l éternel lumière et elle me
laisse en compagnie de jacques brel
edith piaf léo ferré mais aussi mozart
mahler et charles le rythm and blues
sur ces à chaque fois qu'elle met la
musique je me calme alors elle vous a
mis aux bonnes moeurs commis au judo à
ce moment là au judo au dojo et vous
êtes arrivé la même histoire quand
aurélie dupont
c'est incroyable ce mercredi un jour
elle va je puis à quelques cours elle
entend de la musique elle marche jusqu'à
la grande salle d'où venait la musique
et c'était un cours des gt1 cours de
danse voilà ça a été pour elle la
révélation et pour vous c'est exactement
la même chose si j'ai fondu en larmes
j'ai été bouleversée parce que c'était
arthaud robin stein en fait c'était
encore un mange disque le professeur de
danse pour accompagner ses cours de
danse mettez des disques de rubinstein
qui jouer chopin
ouais et là c'était la fantaisie
impromptu je m'en souviendrai vraiment
toute ma vie je suis resté et il y avait
des filles qui dansaient c'était beau a
été belle
j'ai trouvé ça magnifique et donc j'ai
filé en kimono réveillé ma mère ce qu'un
dimanche matin brrr et donc je lai est
retiré au cours j'ai dit qu'est ce que
c'est madhi mais c'est un cours de danse
idée mais je veux faire ça me dit tu
peux pas j'ai mais pourquoi me dis parce
que faut être le meilleur du monde pour
faire ça et 10 mai mais je lui dis mes
meilleurs du monde mais c'est ça que je
veux faire et leurs parents n'étaient
pas très fortunés un les vengeances
drôlement et des ae roulait pas sur l'or
mais ils ont drôlement aider à réussir à
faire à faire ce que vous voulez et vous
ont surtout trouvé votre votre
entraîneur votre coach je m votre maigre
nevers c'est max bozzoni mac is it est
une ex étoile de l'opéra un jour votre
mareike dans un pressing l'avenue de
versailles a dit vous connaissez pas
quelqu'un qui pourrait donner des cours
à mon fils et d'une dame qui dit mon ex
mari
et voilà et oui mon ex-mari et
professeurs il peut s'occuper votre fils
est donc on est arrivé chez max rue
rodier rapide galles là haut et j'avais
mes chaussons de pointe à la main il me
dit c'est quoi ça je dit pas s'ils sont
mes choses seront très fiers
le 10 mai les garçons ils font pas les
points tout a dit ah bon ils font pas
les pointes et bocsa aux oscars j ai pas
pu aller bien on s'en va il connaît rien
à la danse celui-là ans comme on s'en va
et puis trois jours plus tard j'ai
réfléchi un peu je me suis dit c'est pas
très intelligent ce que je fais donc on
va y aller quand même
alors voilà donc vous travailler le soir
avec lui vous êtes au corps de ballet de
l'opéra enfin vous commencez à prendre
enfin vous êtes à 15 ans et demi vous
vous êtes dispensé par le ministère du
travail
j'étais en gagnent arrive à 15 ans et
alors vous décidé de préparer varna en
varna il faut expliquer ce que c'est
c'est des jeux olympiques 2
c'est là dans la danse les jeux
olympiques c'est à dire qu'il ya
quasiment tous les pays représentés il
ya 750 concurrents vous décidez de faire
varna lucien votre beau père murphy est
quand même facilite pas les choses
vous y allez c'est en juillet 76 et la
dernière épreuve au moment fatidique la
bande magnétique sur laquelle vous
demande ces casse ça casse
il soigne et une fille qui monte sur le
sur scène quelqu'un du public à jouer il
joue qui a joué du piano combret et
voilà et je remporte le jackpot erlinder
il n'avait pas été donné depuis dix ans
ouais abbas était baryshnikov le et là
votre carrière explose êtes une star
patrick dupond 17 ans kadri de l'opéra
il vient de remporter le grand prix du
festival international de danse de varna
un triomphe éclatant puisque ce prix n'a
été attribué que deux fois depuis la
fondation du concours en 1964 de la
graine des toiles dit on déjà
[Musique]
à
et bon
[Musique]
e
et voilà ça c'est fait 1965 alors vas
pas faire toute la carrière de patrick
dupond montclus jeunesse que en tout est
dans le livre
faut lire ce bouquin alors bon après il
des problèmes avec l'opéra on va pas on
va pas en parler si ce n'est que vous
venez de gagner quand même un million et
demi de francs parce que vous avez été
viré de façon un peu illégal et donc
vous venez de gagner votre procès contre
l'opéra de paris
donc vous avez un million et demi de
francs oui ça correspond au salaire que
j'ai pas perçu pendant trois ans et demi
et ça correspond surtout à l'argent que
je vais pouvoir mettre de côté pour ma
retraite quoi parce que nous les
danseurs
moi j'ai 41 ans pour le poids l'opéra je
suis un vieux palaja
je suis fini et là il ya eu après votre
période noire c'est à dire vous avez eu
comme on dit les boules quoi servent
celui des ganglions au couple est fait
opérer aux autres j'étais diagnostic et
ont recherché le cancer enfin bon je
suis passé par toute une série
d'épreuves pas drôle parce que la série
noire c'était après la lumière je suis
plongé dans l'eau j'enlève les conduit
en touche en herbe et paralysé du bras
en fait tomber dans l'écueil que j'ai
écrit le livre pour faire leur éducation
j'ai connaissez vous tombé dans
l'escalier béjart vous près de sa maison
à montreux pour allez vous reposer elle
brûle quand vous étiez vraiment que
c'était s'était mis sur son frère lequel
le 4ème et 5ème matin le 5e c'était le
soir maurice m'appelle en me disant
écoute je suis à osaka en est en juillet
tu croiras jamais il mais il fait un
froid de canard ça me fait penser qu'il
faut qu'ils fassent du feu et je lui
mets tous les soirs j'en fais vous
inquiétez pas mauricie fait pas froid
dans le chalet donc le soir en bonne
élève je fais un bon petit feu puis je
me couchais vers 10h30 il ya 4 heures du
matin tout brûle avec moi dans le chalet
brûle avec moi les chiens et le
manuscrit du livre et donc j'ai eu le
temps de sauver les chiens d'abord le
manuscrit ensuite et mon pyjama
après l'accident on a parlé tout à
l'heure donc le 6 janvier 2010 voilà
puis aujourd'hui vous êtes là et on est
ravi qu'ils relèvent dans trois ou oui
dans trois jours le rideau se lève et je
suis vraiment heureux bien mieux on est
très heureux qu ils soient les bras
[Applaudissements]
bien
[Musique]
vient alors patrick dupont on va faire
une interview dernier clou battre dans
le single
[Musique]
des kadhafi est plus là voilà je
constate que cette personne bouge merci
ça me fait très plaisir et je tiens
beaucoup à ça alors dernier coup c'est
facile dernier coup dur panier vous dire
l'accident de voiture l'accident dernier
coup de coeur coups de coeur adriana
karembeu je comprends le dernier dernier
passait il ya cinq minutes et qu'on
confond j'avais bien dans les coups de
poing dernier coup de poing le procès
ouais dernier coup de folie
dernier coup de folie un très joli
cadeau pour maman dernier coup de foudre
dernier coup de foudre obama petit
partenaire maintenant landowski à huy
fab dans les coups de gueule dernier
coup de gueule je veux qu'on m'écoute
aux répétitions
ah oui je veux travailler alors il veut
répéter je trouve qu'on passe trop de
temps sur les autres passez sur moi
dernier coup de bluff dernier coup de
bluff
quand est ce que je le fais je bluffe
tout le temps mais sauf lave sauf ce
soir là pouvaient pas essayer un dernier
coup de barre dernier coup de barre
c'était ce matin à 10h30
j'étais accroché à la barre ah oui
dernier avec lui c'est normal
bienvenue coup de blues
dernier coup de blues olala yaba ya deux
jours je rentre à la maison crevé il
était minuit et demi je mets la radio
évidemment c'est barbara qui chante
l'aigle noir et chef du niagara
ça m'est arrivé avec le raf a bu en main
[Applaudissements]
bien des coups de poker dernier coup de
poker je serais tenté de dire le procès
aussi parce qu'on sait jamais si on va
gagner au père noël heureusement or là
c'est la justice qui a gagné donc tomber
attention patrick dupond dernier couvre
un dernier coup de rein pas plus tard
qu'avant-hier soir ça s'est bien passé
or génial
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah oui c'est comme ça ici que tu dire
ici vous savez quand on dit tout le
monde en parle ça veut pas dire que tout
le monde en parle ça veut dire que tout
le monde en parle bien vous vous
intéressez à l'astrologie vous
intéresse-t-il la main un peu puisqu'il
ya quatre ans je rencontre quelqu'un que
je connaissais pas me dit 4 5 ans
d'ailleurs me dire oh la la il ya un
tunnel noir je m'y attendais je suis
directeur de la danse à l'opéra ça va
merci
et puis en fait tout ce qu'elle m'a dit
dans l'état vous croyez au surnaturel ou
si vous avez vu le chien a précisé que
le projet était confronté à d expérience
vraiment un petit peu comme guy avec la
mort de sa maman quand le au moment où
lucien est mort j'étais en train dîner
avec une copine quai de jemmapes lui il
était à brie-comte-robert et dans la
baie vitrée
j'ai vu son visage vraiment et d'un seul
coup il n'était pas là et qu'elle
quelques une heure plus tard on
apprenait qu'il était mort alors elle
précise où il m'était apparu et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous il m'était impossible
eux